imagine an actor was asked to imitate
you for a day they need to do all the
things you do behave the way you do and
the only research you can provide as a
book that gives them to know how to act
exactly like you what would you write in
this book listing facts about yourself
won't be enough in order for the actor
to imitate you you'd need to record how
you do things we call this procedural
knowledge or knowing how and when we
write down procedural knowledge we end
up with what's called an algorithm an
algorithm is a sequence of instructions
for how to do things throughout history
we've communicated our know-how through
storytelling at first these stories were
shared orally starting with the earliest
forms of painting people depicted
stories as images of things happening
across time at first we did this with
picture sequences and later letter
sequences but we can think of the key
stages in a story as steps and this is
the basis of algorithmic thinking the
ability to break how we do things into a
step-by-step procedure in the most basic
form an algorithm is just a linear
sequence of steps a single pathway of
action but now think of something more
complex that you do which can't be
easily expressed as a simple list of
steps when you try writing down the
steps for how you do these complex
things you'll notice you won't follow
the same linear pathway each time there
is a conditional future practically this
means the word if will pop up in your
list of steps and every time we say if
it means our pathway of action will
branch into possible futures
no matter how far back you look in our
written records you will find if then
pairings used to describe our knowledge
about the world early records of omens
were messages from the gods about the
future for example in ancient Greece it
was believed that the gods made
decisions in an assembly concerning the
course of the world's affairs and the
fate of human beings and they delivered
these predictions about the future in
the form of omens for example they are
typically structured as if followed by a
sign in the natural world and then
followed by the resulting event across
cultures ancient documents have been
discovered which contain lists of omens
that people could consult to better
understand the fate of their lives
and they can be viewed as an early form
of science or proto science an attempt
to describe the world
so it's these if-then statements or what
we call conditional statements that will
help you define the complex things you
do and with that we have everything we
need to define algorithms algorithms are
one a sequence of steps and to these
steps can contain conditional statements
and you can describe anything that is
describable using just these two
concepts no matter how an algorithm is
run a human actor following instructions
or computer following machine code at
some level it's understood to be
following discrete steps resulting in a
pathway of execution and each step in
this pathway takes some amount of time
so the expected number of steps it takes
a process to finish defines the time
resource or time complexity of an
algorithm and while a machine or human
is following or running an algorithm it
may need to store or retrieve
information which must be recorded in
memory and memory
no matter the form takes some amount of
space for example when you follow the
steps in the algorithm for
multiplication or long division at
certain steps you need to write down
extra numbers that allow you to arrive
at the answer these extra numbers are
the memory resource of those algorithms
and the total amount of memory needed
measured as the number of symbols
defines the space resource or space
complexity of an algorithm so when we
run any algorithm no matter what it
describes it results in some pathway of
action and in the modern study of
algorithms we always come back to two
big questions one how much time and
space does it need
and to how can we be sure that the
output of our algorithm is correct
because anytime we hit a conditional
statement before we can take our next
step we'll need to confirm at some level
if something is true or not but how do
we ever really know if something is true
or false and this requires some form of
logic don't suppose for a moment at
least I don't I am not naive enough to
suppose that the International Business
Machines Corporation made this machine
to play checkers it made this machine as
a working model of decision making
machines such machines could conceivably
be used to play other games than
checkers the business game the raw game
the game of determining when to press
the button for Armageddon for the
thermonuclear war
you